in guatemala's national palace
u.s vice president kamala harris issued
a blunt message
to central american migrants looking to
travel
to the united states i want to be clear
to folks in this region who are thinking
about making
that dangerous trek to the united states
mexico border
do not come do not come
harris was tasked in march by president
joe biden
to help stem the record flow of migrants
that have surged along the southern
border of the united states and mexico
since he took office a majority from
guatemala
well standing next to harris in remarks
to the press
guatemalan president alejandro giamette
said the solution
is increased economic opportunity so
migrants will choose to stay
in their homeland people leave due to a
lack of opportunities
municipalities that are areas of greater
migration
coincide with the areas where poverty is
greater
so we need to fight poverty but
corruption
is another challenge the united states
has given guatemala more than 1.6
billion in aid over the past decade
to fight economic instability and
violence
but residents of this struggling
neighborhood in guatemala city
say that money rarely reaches those that
need it
guatemala is in an economic crisis the
country doesn't produce a lot of jobs so
the youth turn to violence
the biden administration has already
committed to sending
310 million to the region it's part of a
four billion
four-year plan to improve the economy in
central america
still other residents are skeptical
harris's diplomatic visit
will result in any real change
i feel it would be good if she came to
visit us to help the kids to help my
neighbors
we need the help here it's criticism
harris is
also facing back in the united states
republicans argue
harris needs to visit the u.s mexico
border to see the problem of migration
first hand but harris insists that's not
necessary i came here to be here on the
ground
to speak with the leader of this nation
around what we can do
in a way that is significant is
tangible and has real results and i will
continue to be focused
on that kind of work as opposed to grand
gestures
the surge of migrants from central
america to
the united states is a problem that has
been years in the making and will not be
solved with just one meeting
that's why the u.s vice president on
tuesday will also be meeting with the
president
of mexico as the leaders continue to
collaborate
and find a solution kimberly hellcat al
jazeera guatemala city